two
okay it's families episode number nine
mom mom specifically
you now are
the subject of intense youtube drama my
goodness
and well before we get into that today's
episode sponsored by policy genius ting
bright sellers and quib thank you for
supporting us also shout out to teddy
fresh our presenting sponsor today yes
on thursday on thursday there's a jerry
garcia collaboration i'm passionate
about jerry garcia
this is something i personally pursued
i'm a deadhead
there's a bunch of really really cool
stuff that is very by the way all the
pieces come with like a freaking guitar
pick oh get out yeah
oh wow that is so cool on the tag oh and
it says teddy fresh yeah
it's teddy
that's really cool and then this is
coming out at the end of the month
should i stand up yes stand up show it
yeah
yeah work it out
work it work it work it try not to work
it work it okay whoa mom
can you see the hood yeah this is so
cute this is really so that's obviously
coming out for the women for the ladies
um here's a little uh preview of what's
coming out on garcia
this thursday
oh wow
uh this and so much more cool stuff oh
wow that is really cool and follow teddy
fresh on instagram for all the updates
um thank you thank you peace and love
thank you can i get a shirt from my
neighbor uh your neighbor yeah
yeah what's next you're grosser well no
he's just a big fan oh of course i'm
kidding of course you can get whatever
you want mom all right thank you you got
the ultimate
hook up
thank you and how many teddy fresh
t-shirts i have in the closet we can
give him one of those i think you want
to give them one of your uses no hardly
used no you would do that that just
reminded me of a story listen to this
[ __ ]
listen to this [ __ ]
you are going to get so busted now tell
me what you think tell me if you if you
think this is bad or not so
when i was about let's say 13
i used to rollerblade i know shocking
confession i'm sorry it's embarrassing
end line yeah that was popular
rollerblader i'm just kidding okay there
was like a rivalry between skateboarders
and uh rollerbladers they would say
they would say the skateboarders used to
say this joke which i don't condone i'm
only saying it for posterity's sake and
i'm sorry to do this but the
skateboarders would say do you know
what's the hardest thing about being a
skater
telling your parents that you're gay
oh god
that's really i never heard that but you
said skater though
did you mean rollerblader yeah i was a
rollerblader i meant like well skater
blader later i guess that was scary
oh my god who won that anyway listen i
disavow that i never said that joke i
was i find it in poor taste
a horrible thing that we used to say
only saying for posterity
that's fair thank you mom yes
you always have my best interests at
heart i always do always
so anyway i put out a a pair of inline
skates
that were at the curb i think you were
set you were donating them to goodwill
right
i don't remember i don't remember that
either i think that there was like you
guys used to schedule like goodwill they
would come and pick up a bunch of junk
and fly oh i did that i did that yeah
and so the neighbor
our next door neighbor
um
who we were always in rivalry with you
remember
yeah they were always like throwing
rocks at our dogs or squirting our dogs
and me and sean once left a piece of dog
poop on their front oh i remember them
they weren't our next-door neighbors
they lived around the block no they were
our next door neighbor no no no no no
because our next neighbors were really
sweet
you believed that dan
no no we liked them i'm telling you we
had a bitter rivalry with them and
spunky ate their rabbit
she listen the rabbit burrowed
underneath i didn't know about the fence
oh yeah oh they hated us i don't know
you're talking no
they had a pet rabbit that burned under
them right into our yard no they hated
us because our dogs wouldn't ever shut
up and it was driving them mad
our dogs would never stop barking ever i
don't remember
water at them
what really they would bark all day
poor guy he worked at home he worked at
home and he was losing he would
wasn't he a teacher he stopped saying
names let's not say name okay i thought
you're thinking on the other side
so anyway there's this biddle in my mind
and then one time they were so mean to
our dogs all the time that me and my
brother we were so young we were
probably like 10. we went and took a dog
poop and
smeared it on their door oh my god you
did that i blame that was shawn's idea
such a troublemaker yeah oh yeah oh my
god
being sarcastic i am
dude sean was a punk dude when he was
that age he was doing it and blaming me
are you talking
are sean or sean yes our sean we were
john the other we were protecting we
were standing up for our dogs i thought
he was like the the
well it was shawn's idea to rub dog [ __ ]
i'm gonna have to talk to him about that
we did
anyway there's there was always a bunch
of [ __ ]
literally
and so anyway so there's a pair of in
line skates
in the front it's basically garbage and
he comes knocking on the door he goes
hey you know uh or he asks me
he goes
hey ethan
uh if you guys are just getting rid of
that my son would love to have those can
i have these and i said let me go ask my
dad i go inside and ask my dad he's like
watching tv or something he doesn't care
he goes
he goes yeah tell him uh 20 bucks
what
i don't remember that and so i went out
and then went to the neighbor my dad
says 20 bucks
and what'd he say he said i'll fine and
he went and got 20 bucks
are you kidding me i swear to god and i
went back and gave the 20 bucks to dad
he never even moved
i have that twenty dollar bill framed
but it's like he shook down our neighbor
for something
why did i not know about this
again i don't remember it's not
hysterical
it's branded in my brain
20 bucks i had to go back and be like my
dad says 20 bucks oh my god all right
well wow so what do you think dan is
that pretty bad or or
he's that's horrible i mean america i'm
getting to know your dad pretty well
here and uh
it sounds like par for the course he's a
hustler what can you say yeah he saw a
way to make 20 bucks
i think i did get like five bucks out of
it so i was pretty stoked you got a
commission what are you complaining
about i gotta cut thank you but i had to
be a little punk ass hustling our
neighbor oh my god and then you just
were sitting watching tv
but you would think you would be like
yeah of course you can have that i'm
still traumatized about the poop
well it's things like that
i
and he's like your kids
did this and then we had to go over
there and clean it and apologize which
was you mean wow
yeah you didn't mention that you got
busted yeah we got busted oh well good
i'm glad that you got busted
no recollection of that i don't know i
don't remember that you guys think that
we were like best friends with them and
i'm telling you you did i really
oh my god i had no idea
they hated the whole family wow
yeah and here i'm going la di da i think
they're so nice they hate they i
remember once they came over he's like
you guys need to install a shock collar
on your dogs because they will not shut
the [ __ ] up and they're ruining my life
wow
you guys were like the nerve of him to
come over and
put on a shotgun you guys don't remember
that huh i don't i although i thought it
was odd that they helped us move things
when we were ready to move that was oh
yeah kind of unusual yeah let's get the
clients out of it when we moved in the
first thing she did was knock on the
door and say do you guys need a vacuum
cleaned yeah it was nice she was really
sad before they knew us yeah exactly
before they knew us
or she was nice in the beginning
oh no
but we were there for like what ten
years or something no we never lived
anywhere for ten years you know we lived
in mexico longer than we ever lived in
any one spot
we were only there for five years i feel
like i grew up my whole
well we stayed in ventura we just moved
around from different houses yeah well
anyway i remember them they hated us
that's the story about my dad
that's true
yeah we felt like we were the nightmare
god
i thought we were
getting along with all of our neighbors
our other neighbor brought us a plan the
truth is you guys weren't at home so me
and sean were at home with the dogs and
they would not they wouldn't listen to
anybody they would just bark and bark
and bark and bark and so we were there
when the neighbors were like shouting at
them and squirting the hose at them and
throwing rocks over the fence at them
wow oh my god maybe because we were
working so much
yeah you guys were never home
me and sean were fighting a war all
right good job good job well you guys
didn't even know what the hell was going
on
oh my god
oh lord so anyway uh who's your mother
who raised you
nobody raised me that's the problem the
wolves the world yeah exactly
so i was speaking of which we're
actually speaking of nobody raising me
we're actually part of the episode today
is we're going to be doing a fan family
bonding speed run okay so dad we're
gonna do the things you never taught me
like throwing baseball tying a tie
you're gonna give me a birds and the
bees talk but you're only gonna have
about like 30 seconds to do each
okay i'm starting to think and then mom
you're going to teach me how to knit
you're also going to give me birds in
the bees talks and you're going to tell
me how to plant milk weeds but only in
30 seconds so can i confess something
sure i don't know how to knit
well then i guess we're gonna well you
know what teach me you know what we can
i can i'm a fast i'm a fast learner
maybe you can teach me how to talk to
girls
talk to girls talk to girls is it that
is more dad's job yeah
what's something that a mom teaches
their son i can teach you how to knit
i'll teach you how you you know what
grammar we're doing knitting we said
grandma anne
was an incredible knitter so i watched
her so i yeah i'll figure it out okay so
but before we get into all that we've
got a lot here to talk about slang term
you guys get your bonus 100 100. today
your slang term is all facts
although a printer all facts yes so that
will be spelled f-a-x right not
f-a-c-t-s right all factors no printer
okay what does it mean all facts
no printer would you would you like to
guess the meaning oh yeah um
all facts
well facts is a no problem now already
uh
old-fashioned hardly used manner of
transmitting communications right a fax
machine opposed to a printer very good
very good all facts no printing
certainly onto something there so
basically
say
um show it don't write it
show it
don't write it and no dad you got to
guess
facts no printer
say i would say all
irrelevant stuff and nothing important
so you're saying none of it's a rel it's
all irrelevant
but but it's all facts
f-a-x okay so what it means
what it means is it's all true
it's all true it's all facts
no printer it's a play on words
all facts
no print
maybe somewhere stupid came up with that
and just couldn't spell well no i think
it's pretty good
so basically that's when you want to
cosign something so if i say like you
know that burrito was uh
sharky's has the best burrito all facts
no printer
okay so that's your word 100 bucks no
all facts no printer yes ma'am so you
think sharky's has the best burrito no
okay
no definitely not
still traumatized
eating sharkies so much years ago okay
well we got to talk about
first of all
the
oh boy you guys really
you guys yeah what do you mean you guys
i'm not responsible for this mess oh for
what you said you're not okay
first of all
before we get into this give a little
context of my mom's literacy literacy on
twitter
she she got into an internet beef with
trisha paytas which is like what the f
so just to give you guys a little bit of
the literacy of my mom on twitter is
that she when she's trying to share
photos she pastes links from her phone
and i don't know why you erase this
ended up getting like 10 000 likes i
know everyone said don't recycle but it
doesn't make any sense because you can't
pull up the image so i erased it and
everyone cannot believe it why did you
do that i was like funny i thought well
that doesn't make any sense to me
that's going to be your best tweet ever
and you and you erased it yeah
well anyway
so you know i tweeted out the image of
trisha with keemstar and i said it made
me sad
and um
so my mom immediately was like oh no
like whatever i expressed i literally
just said it was sad and then when i saw
my mom getting involved i was like oh no
no what is mom doing
mom said
what i'm feeling doesn't fit the word
she's such a weasel what does that mean
you're what you're feeling doesn't fit
the words i didn't how i how i felt
what i was feeling you know how can you
put it in words okay
you were you were that upset i was
really upset can i tell you why i was so
upset please okay um
she's wearing your your merchandise the
frenemies hoodie yeah right
um
this guy who i've read so much about
is not well liked by anybody
he's got such shooting freudia
freuda or schadenfreude has no it's it's
shoot him up freuda if you look it up
it's shad and freud ah
anyway
with someone else's problems and and and
he's the biggest piece he's he's not a
very i mean he's not he's harassed ila
for years saying she looks like a horse
yeah i mean talk about harassment that's
only the best just i know i mean
keemstar has lied about us stealing
money for you i mean the guys i don't
know him all that well i just know what
i read about him and it wasn't
it wasn't in a good light at all he
wasn't he's not well liked by a lot of a
lot of people yeah people yeah and the
fact
that she got and
this is interesting because when this
came out well let me you know what i'd
like to put a shout out
to somebody okay and because it's all
tied into this picture
okay okay first of all since dad and i
have been
with you
on this
format on our family podcast family
journey yes
um
i have grown to enjoy watching
tea tea your tea i'm a tea i'm a tea
connoisseur and there's three people
that i'd like to put a shout out to all
right
and i enjoy i think they're all
intelligent i think they're have a lot
of charisma i think they're going to be
extremely successful
whatever let's send them a milkweed from
donna well no i want to keep those
milkweeds
oh we're not gonna oh oh oh yeah oh yeah
no no no no no
i have some rollerblades we could send
them yeah no we can send them in milk
yeah maybe we can use rollies
one of them
is a young lady uh and her her podcast
or her tea thing
is called hot tea
tea yes she's really good
i like her
hot tea and she's beautiful by the way
she is a really beautiful girl
um have i not heard of this
i don't know but she's great i really
enjoy her channel and then there's
another guy
wet noodle
i think it's definitely definitely by
the way wet noodle is kind of derogatory
isn't it i don't know i thought that was
that's what i wrote down isn't a wet
noodle something like boring
you still call someone a wet noodle it's
like the rug i don't know maybe that's
what he's no i don't i don't know anyway
i know him yeah i'm gonna do it deaf
noodles okay you like him yeah well you
know sometimes he's got ucla stuff on i
don't know he's an alumni but he's
obviously a fan
but he's very smart love duff and and i
really enjoy watching him
and the third person
who i absolutely love
is adam mcintyre oh yeah you guys have a
i
really like him he's smart he's
intuitive
he's charismatic oh my god no the kid i
i like him too the kid is great he's
really great really supportive
i wish i i wish i got that much that
amount of support from you growing up oh
come on ethan i'd be so you might be
so much better adjusted oh please anyway
i was watching
i'm jealous of adam mcintyre of the
praise he's getting from my mom
[Laughter]
i was watching his his channel he's in
spain right now
and at least he was when i was watching
his channel anyway he
had an observation that i thought was
very astute
about keemstar
and this whole this whole photo of the
three of them
and he said it's interesting that they
put this stuff out and he actually knew
that you couldn't uh
post your videos
for a week oh yeah and it basically
he i think his fingerprints are behind
this whole thing it's his scores
that that
you know oh and that's all everybody
knows that you're saying it's keemstar's
fault that i got suspended
not adam's fault no not adam's fault
everybody knows it was keemstar's fault
you literally admit it right he said but
but the mere fact that you couldn't
you know respond they put that up there
knowing you weren't going to be able to
respond and they're sitting there and
he's giving you this gesture he's
flipping me off with his finger for sure
you know i mean it's it's a real in your
face and if she's supposed to be
your
uh
sister-in-law what kind of a
what is that she obviously doesn't like
me very much
but anyway listen let's talk about let's
talk about your
anyways good job you guys i love those
three
two channels
we love the tea
we love them
so what you said is uh she's a weasel
and then you also said this was your
first one and then i was like man i
don't know why you had to tweet twice
because the first one was like i was
like okay it's a little bit of a you see
can't wait to go to our wedding not
it's like wow i was being
snooty you know what's funny is this one
it comes off as a joke but i know when i
read it then my mom meant it like no i
was just being snooty you were being
snooty i was i was being snooty
i think
do you what do you what
what i was being snooty i mean you know
i i did you i'm not in the angel i'm
did you expect it to get 20 000 likes
because it like blew up and all the
teachers you know and then trisha which
we'll get into like responded to you my
first tweet was this is my first tweet i
mean i didn't
well that was who knew yeah you know
that i was gonna get and what's people
watching and all that i just you know
this whole thing is above me no you
don't know what's going on i don't i
really don't
that's that's kind of the beauty of it i
guess i really didn't know what's going
on and so
i don't
i think so to me okay so let me reach
forward it's fun i'm having fun all
right
all right fair enough you know she can
say all these terrible things
i don't care trisha responded it's fun
you called her a weasel churchill
responded what you texted moses is the
most evil thing to ever put out into the
universe if i'm a weasel you are satan
oh my goodness she thinks i cast a spell
on her too she said you are satan for
even putting that energy out there
you're an evil woman to write down what
you wrote it's unspeakable to put that
burden on me the way you did is the
worst karma and then she continues she
said i wonder why she just didn't post
what i said maybe because she knows it's
not gonna everyone's gonna take the
steam out of their balloon she i'll
continue she says the air out of there
below what ethan's mom texted moses
after our fight was the most disgusting
thing i've ever heard
i'm tormented with it daily i won't even
speak what she wrote because i refute
that energy that negative bad energy is
something that paralyzed me that now and
then i mean she's clearly not paralyzed
by it she's literally
and adam pointed out that she called
another youtuber a weasel
oh she has called she has she has called
someone a weasel ethan ran my mom and
said okay here we go
please
i don't need to get in all this but i'm
livid i'm angry i've been carrying this
evil ugly burden she placed on me
um blaming me for an unspeakable thing
she's evil
i just have never encountered anyone to
put such an evil burden on me a curse
a curse on your family
something to even write unfathomable
okay so trisha's been kind of
she's been talking and talking about
like uh you know
what is this thing that you told her i
think we should just i can read it yeah
let's just read it it must be so
horrific don't we need some kind of word
okay let me set that let me give you a
little bit of a backstory okay when i i
tweeted a private message
to moses no no no you texted him no it
was on messenger
okay but you didn't tweet it no no no no
no no tweet oh did i i didn't mean that
yeah
no no i do i sent it on a tweet and a
message
well it was on messenger it's private
and what's the difference between the
two tweet everybody can read it
okay all right
i'll accept that you know that's the
only difference no this was a this is
before families even existed okay okay
and before you are a celebrity
okay if that's what you want to call it
yeah
all of our personal interactions with
her had been fine they were over
to your house for passover and we were
very cordial and everyone was friendly
there was a little bit of a beef when me
and trisha were
talking about that the food was bad and
i know that that upsetted you guys which
i accept i accept the blame for that i
should know jessica made the chicken and
i thought it was really good yeah and
jessica's a great chef so that's that's
that's unfair yeah but we've made amends
for that right yeah but let me give you
let me for a lot of you who don't
understand the jewish culture
there is a language that's specifically
to trisha
no no to the fans for people to
to
understand
there is a language called yiddish
and so many of you use words that you
don't even know are yiddish like like
for example the word tush which means
you know your bum your derry air it's a
cute word a lot of people use a lot of
yiddish words one of the words which you
probably have never heard it's called
machinister
and it means family of your family so
it's your family but it's a little more
extended and whenever we went well
whenever the few times that we were uh
we were with trisha it was the last time
i think was a holiday a jewish holiday
it was at your home
yours in ela's home
and she was there with moses
uh before that before moses even started
dating her we at our house i think is
when we were in the apartment
um we yeah uh in uh in 2000 okay well
whatever
oh no way
yes yes i was we had the big round table
remember we were all so squishy that was
so long ago yeah it was a long time ago
well it was before he ever knew her
dad's saying no well i thought she was
gonna say trisha was there no no no no
no no she wasn't there before so what's
the point moses i'm just saying he was
there oh you it was a holiday it was a
holiday and he is you're talking about
included you know yeah okay i mean we're
we're family yeah so a lot of people
don't you know i've had a lot of
comments saying oh she's not even your
family moses isn't your family but in
the jewish religion they are jewish
people i mean that's not it's not that
like it's extended
he's he's my wife's brother yeah yeah
yeah with us all the time right exactly
he's with us on every holiday right
right
so you know we interact with with your
brother and she's been over here too yes
absolutely so um
yeah so where was i going with this i
don't know i don't
i got so off the track i don't remember
um
oh yeah so i sent this is before thank
you dan yes
um this is before families even existed
ela has been trying so hard to get
pregnant and if any of you have gone
through this program
is it called in vitro is that no we
didn't do in vintro what did you do it
was we did it's like fertility treatment
which is right before vintro we
turkey-basted her with my uh right and
you know what it's really hard i mean i
can tell you all
we talked about a lot but like yeah i
mean we were doing this for a few months
and it didn't work and then it finally
stuck but it was a horrible process
where she was taking i was giving her
shots in the stomach right of this like
saline solution it was super painful so
she's sitting there like arriving in
pain as i injected her every night
actually no we i think we were doing it
several times a day
she was taking these hormones that were
messing her up and it was just a really
hairy it was really harrowing and then
eela finally very expensive as well yes
and and uh and
she finally gets pregnant we were all
thrilled and then we find out that maybe
you guys are having a multiple yeah
birth yeah you know and when you have
twins possibly triplets you have to be
really careful
you know
i mean i've lost a pregnancy
right and it can be
really hard
the further you get along the less
likely like uh miscarriages but in the
first three months miscarriage can be
extremely calm
it can it can be very common and when
you're trying to get pregnant for a very
long time
it can be
it can be heart-wrenching yeah so
trisha just kept on going on and on and
on with some of the things that she was
saying
i didn't understand let's be honest to
be your team ethan obviously you're team
ethan and ela so i know
she she said some things that were just
i'm sorry
you know okay you're my son yeah eel is
my daughter-in-law of course i am
absolute i am
i'm a grandma i you know teddy is my
my uh son and moon and my granddaughter
eleanor same thing and the baby in your
wife's tummy is you know it's really
it's important i'm grandma okay all
right so
i got so upset with all the stress by
the way and i didn't know she sent this
right until
god how did i find out but i would i'll
be honest i was a little horrified
to know that you were texting i it was
moses it was one time uh but you know
what i also at the other hand i get it
you know i get why you sent it
well i was so upset because of some of
the things that she had just okay go
ahead read the title i sent a private
message on messages
you texted moses i mean it's not well i
didn't really tech did is that called
texting yes messaging is that texting
okay
all right this is
everybody this is what i wrote cover
your ears
moses if your sister has a miscarriage
because of this stress
i will hold you and trisha responsible
stop this nonsense enough
that's what i wrote yeah
i'm surprised the message didn't catch
on fire it was so horrid
oh my god so so well okay i mean on one
hand
that's obviously a strongly worded
message
it was and that's how i
felt yeah it was ridiculous she was
causing you
so much stress the truth is we were all
thinking it and i would i wouldn't
wasn't going to write it so when i saw
you read it i was like
she shouldn't have sent the text but
like
i was thinking the same thing honestly
sorry
all facts no printer right yeah that
would be that would have been a good
thing thanks so much 100 bucks
dan dan beat me to it thanks dan she was
just about to say yeah i was just about
to say it
not so like look i mean yeah obviously
that's a lot to tell someone but at the
same time
i get so that that's the message i don't
know you guys can judge for yourself i
get it though like i mean as the grandma
as someone who you're like family with
moses you felt you could speak frankly
with him
at the other hand i i understand that
it's kind of a shocking message to
receive you know as well so you know
that's the message though so you i mean
i think trish is playing it up a little
yeah
i mean come on people can decide for
themselves if she overreacted a little
bit i i cursed her cursing her
you know well at the time it was really
intense it was it was really like she
was making like a billion videos and
tick tocks and elo was in a really
vulnerable point yeah
she had hormones rushing through her
whole body and we were scared
well so there you have it um
let's go ahead and go throw it to a
break and when we come back we are going
to wrap this up i don't want to talk
about trisha anymore ever
i'm i this this is coming out on
saturday or sunday okay i'm doing i did
a big episode on thursday which you guys
saw and this is it i wanted my mom to
speak her piece get her get the
clear the name clear the air or whatever
and now after i have a few more things
to say and we're done trisha will never
be uttered
like voldemort
like baltimore like voldemort
like voldemort
the one who must not be named
or something all right we'll be right
back stay tuned thank you
summer is almost over and responsibility
is about to rear its head again
get ahead of reality and get life
insurance done right flipping now with
policy genius you can get free quotes in
minutes policy genius makes it easy to
compare quotes from over a dozen top
insurers all in one place why compare
well you could save over 50 percent on
life insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius or you could save
1300 or more per year on life insurance
by using policy genius to compare
policies listen you know life insurance
we recently got it it's like you can't
you got to make sure your loved ones are
taken care of absolutely it's a peace of
mind because you know we all it's just
and sometimes you know um
they might fall off the back of a truck
and then you get a big payment a lot of
people your age they have children
and you need life insurance right you do
but if you kill your spouse it doesn't
pay out no i don't think so
just for the record so don't get any
ideas
the license expert at policy genius work
for you not the insurance company so you
can trust them to help you navigate
every step of the shopping and buying
process that kind of services earned
policy genius thousands of five star
reviews across trustpilot and google and
eligible applicants can get covered in
as little as a week thanks to
award-winning policy options that swap
the standard medical exam requirements
for a simple phone call
this exclusive
policy was recently rated number one by
forbes higher than options from ladder
ethos and bestow
that's pretty impressive
very extremely impressive
bestow
you know what i'm about to bestow them
with a with a second class rating
compared to policy genius
listen getting started is easy first
head to
policygenius.com families in minutes you
can work out how much life insurance
coverage you need compare personalized
quotes to find your best price and when
you're ready to apply the policy genius
team will handle the paperwork and
scheduling for free
policy genius doesn't add on extra fees
so head on over to policygenius.com
families to get started right now that's
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right yes
this video is sponsored by h3.ting.com
team mobile is the next generation
mobile that is all online
saves you the money gives you the best
product and you're going to save a bunch
of money and guess what your phone's
going to work and it's going to work
great that's what ting's all about
it's quite a ting
all facts no printer very good
now we're thinking i'm tingling
whether you listen if you're a low data
user or you want unlimited they got the
perfect plan for you and your family
listen to this ten dollars a month for
talk and text ten bucks a month that's
what the heck sounds good you're in the
door man you got a phone you're part of
society ten dollars a month you know you
want data okay 15 a month you know uh
you want unlimited 45 a month you check
out other plans and see what what kind
of works for you but i'm telling you man
these prices are off the ting and off
the ting
that it sounds fair oh it's more than
fair oh it's more than fair
you know everything else you expect from
ting ting mobile is the same they've got
unreal customer service they got
nationwide coverage there's no contracts
they got top-notch account tools plus
you can always bring your current phone
your current phone number to tang with
no strings attached so try team mobile
today i challenge you guys to see how
much you can save and you're going to
get an additional 25
off by going to h3
team
that's all facts and no printer
bright sellers thank you for sponsoring
us brightsellers.com
fam
bright sellers is uh
summer's here
let's drink some wine
it's hard to find new partners in wine
it's hard to figure out what kind of
wine you even like or like even browsing
the aisle finding a good store to pick
wine from with bright cellars you go to
their website you fill out a little
palette quiz based on things you know
you like like your favorite type of
chocolate or your ideal setting to drink
wine and bright cellar ships you six
bottles of wine based on your answers
finding you new favorite wines it's
never been easier that's genius it is i
don't have a clue yeah and you know it's
great for for amateurs yeah connoisseur
is alive yeah dan uh our our resident
lush has uh
service of course he lives pregnant so
i'm not allowed to drink since she's
pregnant it's a solidarity thing dan how
was your experience with bright sellers
it's great yeah and like you said uh you
just fill out a quick little survey and
they send you stuff that they know that
you're gonna like they sent me uh
there was a tetra tetrachroma was the
name it had like a crazy name of uh one
of them that's a promo
tetrachrome where's it from
i don't know where tetrachroma is well
tetrachroma means four colors so um and
what that doesn't really give me
tetra color sounds like the name of a
fish tetras for and chroma is color
right that's true so it's probably a mix
of uh grapes in that case right yeah
that's a good well it was a pinot noir
um okay and it was real good i'm not
sure where
it's from okay but we love it we love it
we loved it regardless it's monterey
california oh beautiful so
it worked for dan uh dan
it worked for dan is that right it
worked it worked it was love at first
sight each wine comes with an education
card that includes information on the
region clearly you didn't read that
yeah
you just cracked that baby open and
i was in a rush and that wine from
tasting notes food pairing and serving
temperatures you always switch up the
amount of reds whites and roses uh if
you're a seasonal wine drinker you can
skip and order whenever you want plus
being a proud seller member means you
get access to the premium wine portfolio
before the wine even hits the market
boom best part is that if you do not
like a bottle of wine bright sellers
offers a delight guarantee i love that
it's not a satisfaction guarantee it's a
delight guarantee
it's better yeah and i was delighted
that there we go and they guaranteed it
to you and we'll send you a replacement
bottle in your next order so listen up
people to help you find your new partner
in wine family is giving you 50
off nice your first six bottle box from
bright sellers by going to
brightsellers.com
fam head to brightsellers.com
fam that's bright sellers b-r-i-g-h-t
c-e-l-l-a-r-s dot com backslash fam to
receive 50 off your first six bottle
order bright sellers helping you
discover wines that you'll love nice
listen guys you know i love quip i've
talked about it and this is the one
to stop toothbrush i am obsessed with
oral hygiene it's so important they say
taking good care of your mouth can even
add
time onto your life yes because if you
don't take good care of your mouth you
get like gum disease and all this
bacteria and it can make like sickness
you can get you can get heart disease
exactly you don't take care of your
teeth yeah so listen the thing that i'm
always super uh obsessed with is this
softness of the bristles yeah i want to
damage your gums and what kwep has
achieved is the softest most gentle but
cleaning bristles in the game and i've
tried everything it's a vibrating little
tube here boom and what it does is it
tells you
when to switch quadrants puts you on a
two minute timer brush brush brush brush
and then a pulsates in 30 seconds brush
brush brush brush so it guarantees you
get that perfect dentist recommended
brush every time that's perfect and it's
vibrating um
oh please yeah i want you to enjoy it
and i accessory it is
how many toothbrushes can you say match
your outfit
um the other thing you know with quip is
that they are rewarding you for good
brushing now with quip smart electric
toothbrush good habits can earn you
great perks like free products gift
cards and more what that freak
um
it's going to track when and how well
you brush you're going to get tips and
coaching to improve your habits you're
going to earn points points for daily
brushes and bonus points for completing
challenges like streaks yeah i mean guys
don't skip a day if that's what they
mean just make sure we brush your teeth
every day guys come on yes twice a day
foot soldiers we we brush or monarchs
whatever you are yes dawn arcs don arcs
redeem your rewards for free products
gift cards and discounts from quip and
partners we love love love love that
join the five million miles holy smokes
who use quip and save hundreds compared
to other bluetooth brushes when you get
equipped smart brush for just 45 dollars
this thing's going to last you like man
this thing is i've been using mine for
like a year all right now actually all
you do is pop the the brush head off and
then you you put on a new one you just
change the brush head but the battery
lasts like so i mean it's never died on
me so when you buy the the top
part they send you this yeah
can you get like a number of them
instead of just one yeah no they send
you they put you on a plan and they send
you all the brush heads you need oh it's
genius
start getting rewards for brett you have
use that one let give us a review next
time start getting rewards for brushing
your teeth today go to get quipped.com
families10
right now to save 10
unequip electric toothbrush thank you to
quip that's tender's office smart
electric toothbrush get get equipped dot
com slash families ten spell g-e-t
q-u-i-p dot com slash families ten quip
the good habits company
all right we're back so trish obviously
made a bunch of tick tocks i just want
to give you the chance to respond to
everything
let's clean we'll clear the air and move
on from this
um you're welcome
oh can i how does it feel to be in drama
as like a six-year-old woman
internet b
you know
i'm not used to being in a in a spot
like like this and
you know since i have
done the show with you as as a co-host
you know i'm really learning about this
whole
youtube oh yeah
uh multiverse world and
you know
i gotta say
i like it she likes the drama you're
keemstar it's fun you're a kid star if
keemstar was a mom
i'm keemstar well you love the drama
well no i mean i just love the whole
thing you love youtube i do yeah exactly
everybody loves you i love it i mean i i
think it's a way for all of you guys to
stay close and communicate with you i
mean you know yeah that's negative
positive you're and you're all
those are like your guy how do you feel
dad you watched the tea too well i was
gonna say don't insult your mother like
that first of all come here you're right
i'm sorry vile person i know don't
compare me to him well because you're
like i love the tea that's like
keemstar's thing
oh i'm just kidding of course you're not
keemstar
thank you for that you're welcome yeah
it's been fun you know i
was on twitter before
so i was
slightly more versed in how this works
which isn't saying much of anything
but uh
yeah it's been it's been fun so far i've
i've enjoyed it
yeah it's funny but like to be feuding
with somebody well you know
i think it's different than just using
the internet yeah you know you're an
internet beef that peop the t-channels
are talking about i don't think i i mean
i think it was a knee-jerk reaction
because you're my son
would you know unsend the tweet if you
could yeah i probably would in
retrospect i you know i just think
it was just a knee-jerk reaction i was
just uh like what you're not used to
people even
yeah yeah i had the same reaction
because you know anyway here's what you
said about you on tick-tock
oh sick of this [ __ ]
this is your christian
god you're taking off the invite the
minute you sent moses that text donna
klein
so more about the text that cursed her
for eternity
oh my goodness
you crank it dan
okay
i'm so sick of this [ __ ] i am so
sick of this [ __ ] i can't wait to go
there whatnot and you were taking off
the invite the minute you sent moses
that text they all know what that text
was on the last episode of frenemies
which we also read well now everybody
knows what the text is yeah i that's
okay everyone was recording
i i brought that up i said why would
your mom text the most vile disgusting i
can't even speak it right now i cannot
speak her right now because she puts she
put blame and the weight of something so
heavy on me that i have to wait this out
now talk about her she's a vile scum
i cannot she said she said [ __ ] vile
scum i'm vile and i'm scum pretty
awesome to hear someone talk about my
mom that way in a way
i mean i don't think i don't think any
of us take it seriously but just like
the fact that my mom is being called
vile scum by trisha paytas is something
i've never
expected
yeah
it's crazy it's just crazy repeat i
can't even put out what she said and
when i asked ethan like your mom texted
this
like that that's something that's
unfortunate like the nastiest thing i've
ever heard from anybody and he's like
well i told her not to text that it's
disgusting no i okay she's she's lying i
didn't say i told her not to text that i
didn't know what i said trisha is i
didn't know she sent it
right okay so let's not let's not act
like i was party to that okay
trish is lying you know speaking of
things that trisha has said oh
she made
um a comment about your fans
oh they were occult
you know really nasty things and i got
to tell you since i've been doing this
cameo thing
you're fans i
love your fans
they're smart they're not my fans
anymore they're your fans they left me a
few episodes ago
no no no they are your fans no they're
your fans
i love them they are the only questions
they are the sweetest most respectful
and they're so smart some of these
people are so educated it just blows me
away
you know and and
once in a blue moon i get recognized and
every time someone has come up to dad or
myself just to say hello and tell us
that they enjoy the show
they are just delightful i agree every
every time i get approached on the
street it's always a really positive
experience so i don't know how she can
say this about your fans i just well i
think she's she's getting a different
brunt
i don't i don't i wouldn't say that's
the thing she keeps saying it's all our
fans i think a lot of them are her fans
who are
angry with i don't know that well anyway
let's i don't want to get into all
though let's just stick to the fact well
i just want to say for all my all the
people that
from on
cameo
that asked for me to send them a message
it was so much fun it's been so much fun
i'm still on cameo but i
i really
are you plugging i am plugging am i
plugging
no i mean
even if i never get another one i just
really enjoyed it it was fun
again i'm on cameo also oh my god you
guys
yeah my season
my dad goes my dad you and sister you
should do something man
i want him to do it with me we should do
something funny
where i was like you guys should do it
together and my dad was like no i'm
doing it by myself i did two cameos on
the way over there yeah we've done
and dad was driving it was it was
someone's birthday well mom's got a
couple where they wanted both of us
yeah okay
and i've gotten two so far so i'm oof
how does that feel too small fanbase
well nobody knew that he was on the the
what's your fans called the gear the
beach ball killer
the stab the stabs
gary the stabbers the stabbies what'd
you say then just gary kleiner's
recliners for life yeah there was a lot
of great fan art that people created
oh yeah let's
let's stay on the rails here okay let's
and then we can go to the fan art
it's okay
i forgive you
what she placed on me
is evil it's downright evil i bit my
tongue when she's talked about me and
compare me to gabby i bit it i bit it
but this she put a burden on me that i
ca i will not talk about for a few
months but it's the most disgusting [ __ ]
blaming me for she says apparently she's
got like a big thing she's planning for
when the baby comes because she can be
like okay the baby's out the curse is
lifted and then she's going masked off
by the sound of it
[Music]
i picture you like you know and like uh
what was the name of um
voldemort's uh cl like his um
what were they called
the death you're like oh
that's right sucking out all their
energy yeah for sure and she said i
can't even print it out and go ahead
print it out i know now we know what it
is well maybe we've maybe maybe this is
good for maybe we've lifted the curse by
talking about it
so this now she can feel like she's not
cursed anymore because i don't want her
to feel like she's cursed i know don't
you think you need to tricia i might not
get along i'll go ahead mom's making a
declaration i i might not get along with
you at the moment because of things that
have happened and i don't wish you any
ill will
i would never curse you i would never
tell you who you should love or i would
never say
you know to to leave someone this is
your life your choices
and um
you know
relax
relax that's all okay
you did pretty good until you started to
relax okay
here just slam this
jumper
the curse is lifted you just hit the
dumping button oh oh i did oh no no no
can i un-dump
nope well you can't ring the bell no she
should not no no there it goes they're
in love so they're they are in love i
don't think that's good i don't take
that away from them no no listen okay
here's another one part 10 of uh
down as a
witch ethan sent a hate mob on my sister
for making a tick tock that she deleted
within an hour
what ethan's mom texted moses about me
i hate
your sister lied about me i had to
correct the record uh my mom sent moses
a private message
yeah i mean just it's like so absurd to
compare them and not only that her
sister was there at disney so when she
lies and says something happened that
did it then
but if i don't say anything without her
we wouldn't have five percent to throw
around so we have yeah right thank you
we banished that meme but i think we can
bring it back
what were you saying mom
well i was just kind of saying she
thinks i'm just i'm deceitful but i sent
an a message and i couldn't have been
more open and honest
yeah i think she she calls you conniving
here up how can i be conniving let's get
to the bar too vulnerable and the b word
i just i don't think that way i don't
roll that way no you're not conniving no
unfortunately
i don't have a conniving bone in my body
well here let's listen
putting that is an evil
monster [ __ ] the fact that she even
monsters i can't even speak it because
the fact that she even texted it and put
that in writing was so vile and
disgusting i had never met a more evil
conniving [ __ ] in my life
so she's never met a more evil does that
mean you've replaced gabby as the most
evil
she says you're conniving you texting
moses directly
is the opposite of conniving yeah it's
very direct so yeah but evil [ __ ] we
accept that oh i'm just kidding
i refuse conniving but the rest
well the rest she's entitled to feeling
like oh okay i mean obviously i disagree
but considering she's entitled to her
feelings it doesn't make her right
she just sees it from that point of view
i don't
i don't get it but
you know
she's very angry she's mad at she's just
mad at me and she's lashing out that's
everything never to put that on you do
not know me you don't even know moses
like that and then she has got destiny
and plays that moses she knows moses as
well stop trying to pretend like you
guys are strangers i know for years yeah
years how long have you guys been
together i've
yeah me and you have been together for a
god like 15 years now or more i don't
know
for a long time i know the whole family
yeah moses was shook to not tell me
about it for such a long time and then
once i heard i wonder why
i've been carrying this i've been
sick to my stomach over this i'm just so
terrified of this
of what she said and i'm just
i'm on eggshells okay the curse is
lifted right we lifted this person the
curse whatever that was lifted we lived
dan you're shaking your head no good
oh we have a third video i'm sorry this
is it and then we're done okay
okay
we got to get a soundbite of her calling
my mom an evil conniving [ __ ] to play i
want to know who does her makeup she has
good makeup people right yeah
it's a lot of makeup though i mean i i
wear so little makeup i i wish i could
wear makeup can we not comment on her
appearance of all well no i like oh that
was a compliment yeah well you said it's
a lot of makeup well she does i'm just
saying i can't wear that i mean
i think she looks great my favorite look
is when she looks like she's not wearing
any lipstick or any eye makeup oh yeah
that is my favorite trisha she she looks
great you know she's killing it she got
great makeup we agree right yeah i know
no comments on physical appearance peace
and love peace and love no thank you
thank you
serious message
something nice no no i just wanted to
make sure what you were saying was nice
yeah
i don't want to leave any
dad
his lips are sealed
yeah what the stop don't even do that
don't even do that that's
that's not funny
go ahead say it no no didn't say
anything i thought you were going to do
more of them
how much of that can you do i think they
made my point there here we go
i'm involved in my wedding that you were
not invited to after that nasty vile
comment wait did we watch do not even
talk about my relationship do not even
talk about me because you weren't there
all of this stuff is between me and
ethan if he wants to talk to his family
about this it's fine but it's not a
personal matter it's between me and
ethan and ethan lyon ethan being a
coward ethan being a hypocrite i have
admitted to being all of those and more
she's talking to you now ethan can't and
donna chiming in on this
after she i would hide in embarrassment
and shame after what she texted to moses
shame shame and other people that moses
knows she texts the same thing it's
vital it's the sickest thing a human
could ever say about somebody and to
even speak that even text it what she
texted into existence is
so disgusting and you were all friends
sick you're not by the wedding because
of everything that's been done on the
internet i mean even including your own
son ethan he said some of the sickest
[ __ ] about people what you said is
restarted okay i guess it all kind of
just melts in yeah i was like uh
okay but there you have it okay you know
what now we're coming to the wedding
anyway she can't stop us
that's what i said you guys gotta save
the day right i'm going to come in
disguise did you guys rsvp yes did you
save the day no
no
no we're not giving a warning we're just
showing up in disguise
as hasidic jews
wow
all right listen patricia
saga is over
we've got a new set
out with the old in with the name with
the new this officially ends us talking
about trisha
mom you are not an evil conniving uh
thank you
b word yes i love you i think you're the
opposite of all those things thank you
sweetheart you're definitely not
conniving you're definitely not evil no
and you're definitely not a [ __ ]
oh wow i got a hug for that
thank you
thank you for sticking up for me
i love you even though it caused a
little problem sorry i appreciate the
thought thank you i like how i'm skating
through all of this so we don't want to
get you involved in this
[Laughter]
all right so um you guys want to look at
fan art then we'll do the family bonding
uh speed run okay let's see donna fan
art
here we go look at this
oh my god i haven't seen that operation
mom of the monarchs
oh that's funny
that would be a more donna monarch
or
very nice very great i know
this one is crazy it's me
as the
you're the caterpillar is that i think
i'm like the the
wonder wonderland
[Laughter]
it's a really amazing art i know see
your fans are amazing
they are i don't they really are
caterpillar mentioned oh i love the one
that you're about to show i just think
that's so cute my mom goes first of all
i send this to my mom because i thought
it was super funny and my mom goes how
do you feel about that they're like
checking if i was offended by it yeah
you know because you're sitting in my
lap like you know because i look like
this well no no no i mean you know
you're you're you're a grown man but
you'll always be my little boy oh you
saw it as like i'm your baby yeah so i
thought you were i was offended because
of the depiction of me as like a little
fat
no
no you're a caterpillar right you're a
juicy caterpillar well no i'm not
offended by it mom okay and that's why i
shared it i thought it was cute so shout
out to our lovely fans the fan art yeah
i love you appreciate you
amazing all right let's let's move on to
our main segment here today family speed
run you know i often talk about how i
was uh
uh was uh raised kind of by myself
because you guys were working so much as
a kid and so here today we're going to
be making up for lost time so that being
said let's get right into the
family bonding speed run
what the hell are all these butterflies
doing here
oh wait this is kind of silly lager
you have to teach me how to shave in one
minute so
okay shave are you gonna shave off your
beard i'm gonna do whatever he tells me
he's my dad i'm just here i don't know
what i'm doing i haven't shaved since i
was a kid the guy never taught me how to
do it all right let me go grab my
electric razor
and uh no okay all right we're starting
here one minute now use hot water cold
water right best to wash your face get
some hot water in there soften your
beard up okay this is cold but i mean i
have a washcloth here i'll just do this
okay good good it's so cold okay
let's just shave off half your beard
today okay so what's the other half
continue to grow so what do i do okay so
now we need some shaving cream okay
maybe you know just in a gentle area
there
and then it's not working
oh great nice and clean
shaved every day
always there usually you have to take
that off of the shaving cream can you i
didn't even know that push it okay there
we go yeah that's enough no no no they
think that's enough oh my god no this is
not going in a good place okay
all right now
no don't okay that's good
now you want to shave against the grain
here take this
no thank you but his hair is so long
wouldn't that hurt
what am i supposed to do with this okay
so
like down here we're just gonna put a
little bit there and then you wanna
take the plastic off
oh just like the
cap on the can the bathtub
a cap on the razor also then you're
gonna take your shaver okay that's
enough
do we have a towel
okay i think you've got enough shaving
cream on there
oh my god starting to look like santa
perhaps i just want to make sure it's
nice and soft
it can be too much shaving cream okay so
now what do i do so now we're going to
start down here at the bottom and you're
going to pull up how do i know that's
against the grain
well it's not be well
ah
perfect that's how you know
is it supposed to hurt you know isn't
his beard too long to start doing it a
little bit it's pulling a lot it
shouldn't be painful it is painful all
right well maybe bleeding so that's
perfect no it's not bleeding
so yeah you're just gonna go up like
this wait why does it hurt you're not
being instructive
uh
your hair is pretty long little pieces
and if we were really gonna shave it i
probably would have gone in with the
scissors and cut it down a little bit
and you might have the razor upside down
i don't okay just checking
i don't think so you're a newbie you're
saying i should be doing it like this or
like this yeah but okay so you want
this is one of those newfangled what is
this like 15 blade razors is that good
or bad yeah well no it's supposedly good
it's all marketing
it hurts less when i do it this way yeah
well right well no that's because you're
not doing anything no i'm caught i'm
cutting
there we go that that that's not good
that is more painful i'm telling you you
don't know what you're doing be a man
come on
no pain no gain all right that's it all
right
all right that's fine i'm playing
baseball better it looks much better me
too all right let's see you look great
though i did shave so let's see what's
the result let me walk you're gonna go
watch it off okay
okay so dad clearly your instructions
were really useful based on the fact
that i have not removed anything and i
was trying if you recall i said turn the
razor upside down and he said it hurts
it hurts so what are you talking about
that's what happens
it's appropriate to humiliate your son
when you're trying to teach him
something like
you think that little boy inside of me
has even like uh properly uh healed
i do can can i just say something um go
ahead i
by no means am i a barber or an expert
on this but um i i the whole against the
grain thing is
not not the way that i shave or or did
you know i was gonna save dan yeah and
he what did he tell you i think with the
grinch with the grain
dan's dad said but but i could be wrong
like i'm not saying that's correct but i
was just a little confused as you were
instructed against the grain didn't feel
right
that seems like it would be more painful
excuse me you with the big beard what
was your comment about shaving
well here let's
google it what's the
do i
shave with the grain or against the
grain what the what's with the grain are
we up for it are we against it now we
know if you're cutting a brisket it's
against the grain it's shaving against
the grain
which is what you recommend that's what
i recommend tends to pull the hair
follicles up and away from the skin
which runs an increased chance for razor
burn or scary irritation being left
behind we recommend shaving against the
grain only in areas of your face where
there is stubble left over from your few
passes with the grain
oh so so with the grain first and then
against the grain as as as a
instruments of war only right maybe
that's because you use an electric razor
gary well i think a lot has to do with
uh our family we are not the thickest
bearded people my my i mean well i was
just come on we got gaps i was tearing
hair out of my face i know but we have
thin beards
okay
look at these guys they're they're
much more bearded okay so you're saying
because of our because of our family has
such pathetic facial hair we go against
the grain
okay i'll go with that
great
thanks useful advice should be has to be
something not perfect about us so
there you go
all right we don't grow great beards all
right dashes yes are you guys ready for
your third and final bonding wait what
about birds and the bees
oh
but that's the finale right so you you
don't have a tie tie dad
this little piece of cloth that man we
have one minute we're around there all
right so that's some reason let's go
ahead and start the clock you have one
minute okay here we teach your son how
did i remember no one wears ties these
days okay go ahead okay so we're gonna
take
the tie
right hand left hand right hand side
should be shorter than the left-hand
side
a little longer pull it up a little more
a little more a little more a little
more don't be afraid like so long like
this okay like down to my freaking shins
okay these are very long ties okay now
we're going to take this cross it over
okay then we're going to come up come up
under from the back
right very good
thank you
and then are you proud of me
donna
i used to tie his ties on him i don't
know what you're doing right here i
don't understand that i thought i had
this all
thought out and did you research this
before there we go
you unfight it wait i know i have to not
look at it okay let's see so now i'm
left in the trenches here on step three
maybe i should be teaching him how to
tie a tie
okay all right we gotta go that's a
minute that's it i'm sorry i'm stuck on
step three and you and you have to wear
it like that for the rest of the episode
it's not gonna stay on it's gonna come
off
okay one more wrap
oh god okay
come on
i retired 15 years ago i haven't worn a
tie
yeah right now yeah like you wore a tie
to work i never wore a tie to work
either exactly ties and bike shops all
right thanks for nothing
wait wait
story story of your life and now you
know why he never taught you
there how's that part that's great
all right so shaving and tying is a
disaster
let's move on to the birds and the
beasts the birds and the bees go ahead
all right so once again one minute which
is a talk i never got by the
way really you never got to know kids
kids
don't need talks about the birds excuse
me
i grew up when i grew up the internet
didn't even exist so don't give me that
[ __ ] you kids were so smart i never got
the birds and the bees talk so going
back
what's the appropriate age for birds and
the bees like 13. i got it from my dad
yeah around like 12 maybe even 11
somewhere around there i gave jessica
birds and the beast talked when she was
9. why didn't i get a birds in the bee
stock
we tell we're talking about butterflies
instead
butterflies and the bees but the
butterflies and the bees well why didn't
i get that why did you guys decide
not to engage that conversation with me
i don't know kids all learn from their
friends
that's where i learned
who better to get sex advice from than
your
10 11 year old friends
they must know better is i is you but on
a [ __ ] on a serious note was there any
uh collective decision to just say the
boys are okay
um you know i i could have
given you the talk but i figured dad it
would it'd be you know it could have
been embarrassing having your mother i
know but it didn't happen what happened
you know i
dad you dropped the ball
well
look he's happily married you
i gave jessica the talk but you guys
could have met together and said gary
did you give him the talk yet it's not
all dad's fault is it um you know i
didn't even remember who our neighbors
were so i can't remember that part
is it too late to do that no it's not
too late now it's your chance all right
so pretend i'm 12 okay
all right okay all right one minute on
the clock on the clock educate me and
starting now
you got birds
and you got bees no this is nice they
cannot have babies together
bees can have bees
and birds could have birds but birds and
bees
they can't have babies
why are you telling me all that because
you have to stay within your own species
when you're going to propagate
otherwise it won't work why what do you
i don't understand
well just you have to be a little picky
you know when you're out i'm not [ __ ]
animals i don't know what to do
that's my point
you just have to be picky
about animals
not animals what are you saying i'm not
playing on [ __ ] birds well and then
the stork comes
and there's a baby
it goes just like i'm so confused
which part the birds the bees are the
stork
none of that made any sense to me i'm
pretending i'm 12 and that didn't make
any sense okay
wow that was and that's one minute good
talk good talk guys
well done
yeah did you
your dad actually used the metaphor of
birds and bees to explain sex steal no
no it was a little more straightforward
than that yeah i don't know where to go
from there are we gonna have to put a
parental advisory on this now that we've
discussed such
taboo topic based on that discussion
i don't think so yeah probably not
so um
i told jessica you're confused exactly
what happened and she freaked she said
oh my god that means you've done it
twice
because you know at the at that time it
was just shawn and her that were born
she freaked out all right
i think well do you guys feel closer do
you guys feel like you you've kind of
rekindled the father-son bond definitely
that's great
i'm so glad that we could do that here
on families today i think we've solved
all the problems in the world fantastic
well uh that was that was the worst
birds and bees probably of all time
well it we uh we're not just bonding
fathers and sons here today we are also
bonding mothers all right it's your turn
to bond all right so uh give us one
second and we'll set up for the was my
pleasure my pleasure we'll set it up
with my mom and we'll bring her out so
we'll be back in just a second
okay where mom is going to teach me how
to knit in one minute well i don't
underst i'm already confused what's with
the stuff okay
put one stick down okay take
a hold of one the other stick in your
right hand take the end of the
string
the yarn and make it about this length
okay
this part of the string of the yarn make
yourself a little loop so it looks like
it looks like this little loop okay so
the the front should be the it should
cross over in the front you got a loop
right then take the part that's in the
back and push it through push the loop
and then pull it pull the loop
and you'll have a little knot
got the knot okay
okay you got this i think so okay here
you
wanna
oh make it a little smaller it worked it
did work nice and then you want to take
take note dad take she's actually
teaching me take your right your right
hand and put the stick in there
and then take both strings and tie it
nice and snuck okay we're going to
tighten that right snuggy okay well not
that tight snug it up okay now whoa okay
there you go
now
sorry
now with the string that's got the short
end of the stick
okay hold your hand like this we're
we're technically out of time but this
is going well let's see some more let's
put some more time let's get a little
bonus time okay you got it you got it
like your [ __ ] and your thumb is up just
like your thumbs up thumbs up okay what
you want to do is you want to close your
hand on it
and you want to take your thumb
okay and you want to oops you want to go
behind the the
string and then it's it's looped around
your hand yep okay i'm with you take the
point pointy and go through it like this
yes okay
then with the string that is attached to
the the the
ball wrap it around in front
and then go through here i'm getting a
little lost and pull it
okay
yeah you did it i did it yeah i think so
what do i do now i just have a mega
knife
we just do it um we just do it again
okay what are we doing
the short end what are we creating well
uh whatever you want a scarf a blanket
first we're doing is oh we're just
making like a fabric well it's you're
knitting and the first thing you have to
do is you have to cast
the first just like this
no
no
hold it with the short end i'm losing
patience i lost patience for the process
here look well it's it's kind of
complicated you put you like you're
shaking your hand with your thumb up
shaking your hand thumb up close your
hand close
and put your thumb so that you're
pulling it like this pull it like this
okay come a little closer e all right
time's up ah
time's up
i mean he successfully did one uh i
think i did one yeah that's pretty good
yeah you made some progress okay i was
afraid of this turning into just a
full-on knitting course i was enjoying
myself though to be honest because i was
enjoying it too much i was gonna end up
just sitting here knitting
it's very therapeutic remember rosie
greer
do you remember the big big football
player rosie greer he's the one that
actually uh
his name was rosie
roosevelt rosie for sure rosie greer and
he used to knit
remember
of course rosie greer was a football
player and he was the one that was with
bobby kennedy when he was shot
and he
uh stopped
um okay
his
see your hands seriously
he assassinated
what's the second stick for
well that's when you start to knit [ __ ]
first you have to cast
a row
all right and then thank you mom
that was fun fascinating stuff well you
know it's really about the bonding
between the two of you that takes place
rather than learning cold on a cold day
you sit by the fire on a cozy couch and
you knit you just knit yeah why do old
ladies love knitting or me i mean men
you know what my mother was the most
amazing knitter and she she knit me some
beautiful blankets and sweaters and it's
you pass the time but you also create
for your loved ones yeah and it's very
therapeutic
you know love that yeah it's good
so
so much for those those are it's that's
beautiful yarn too yeah beautiful really
pretty you want it
no oh
i don't need it
all right what do we got here that's
milkweed okay so nobody breathe because
apparently it's it's going to kill
everyone
oh i'm going to get up is that okay
here bring this over here and this
uh samantha
got this for us and it's called narrow
leaf milkweed and this is actually
native this is the goods oh the native
the good stuff this the butterflies love
the narrow leaf is the good stuff this
is the good stuff and it's really hard
to find some place that carries this
were these expensive sam
no not it wasn't expensive but it's uh i
think she's like sixteen dollars she did
have to go to several places to find it
you're right it was kind of funny well
you can get milkweed at various
nurseries but they're not the native
so what are we
what are we learning here today how to
plant how to pot the milkweed i mean are
you gonna take these home
i would love to oh yeah that would be
awesome thank you you're welcome
can't have too much milkweed in your
yard okay so we're gonna oh the idea is
that we're gonna plant these in the pot
that's right you're gonna pot a plant
alright we have one minute mom where's
the there's yours right there
oh we have uh oh pie
okay wow we have to water it afterwards
okay here i'll let you do it okay great
except for i can't open this thing
oh i see it
okay okay there we go all right so all
right go ahead mom we have one minute
one minute are you guys ready really
need to do okay this pot
is
pretty much okay usually you put i put
broken pieces of pottery this is plastic
so it's fine it just so that the
drainage and it doesn't leach through
and looks like we've got drain holes
okay so what you need to do kind of e
you only have a minute okay okay
you just put here hold this okay sure
you just put a little bit on the bottom
that looks like good soil
you know i'm gonna teach you guys a
trick
okay you have one minute i'm gonna teach
you a trick so what you want to do is
you want to put enough
in the middle i mean here wait let me
put a little more okay
you want to put enough on the bottom
and here is a really good trick for
anyone who is a gardener and wants to do
this take your plant it's going to make
such a mess
okay you take the plant out
all right
and what you do is you submerge it in
water
so that it really
gets nice and wet you put the pot
from the old one using this
well you're using it as a form you fill
the dirt around it and then when you
press it and it's all perfect when you
take it out all you have to do is slip
your your plant in it it's perfect
[Music]
that's what you do and that's time
what's the difference if you just put it
in the pot well because it's messy like
this if you like if you have a bunch of
of them you can use the old ones and
then all you do is you you're safe
you're saying you put the soil around
yeah you you i mean we would make a jump
yeah i see i see it but you put it
around and you
you pack it down
and then you put it
once you remove it and so i i
put this in the pot i put it in the
backyard and the butterflies come
they will you if you build it they will
come
or if you plant it they will come we
have two beautiful milkweeds for you
here mom thank you
thank you so much um
and finally of course we have uh
the birds and the bees are well maybe
not about the birds and the bees but
like how to treat a lady presuming i'm
i'm i'm 13 years old and i'm going on my
first date okay well you know what you
have a short memory because actually i
did do this with you you don't remember
but your sister and i
decided that you were going to be a
gentleman and
there was a young lady that you were
you were that you had asked out and uh i
told you
that you know you were driving you were
driving age
and i told you that a lot of girls don't
know what to do when you get out of the
car should she get out of the car are
you gonna open the door what do you do
so i remember telling you when you come
to a stop
you tell
the young lady
that's in the in the seat next to you
your girl your your date
stay here
you tell them
i'm gonna i'll be let me get the door
for you sit here and they know
what to do
you know what i do remember that and
that was good advice that [ __ ] slays for
sure
i'm telling you i do remember that and
then you you're you're prince charming
because it's true it really helps you
you're giving the woman you're removing
the you know anxiety what do i do you're
telling her although these days i don't
think i don't i haven't been i've been
out of the dating game for a while but i
don't think people really
they worry like oh am i going to open my
own door you know they should
they really they guys should open the
door
for their girlfriends how about you and
their wives which you don't do either
who's opening the door for me
what is this
fake equality
well okay you know i just what if fila
was like what if my date's like you know
what stay right there i'm gonna get the
door for you good for her okay i like it
good for her what if everyone both turn
to each other and say stay right there
and then in unison stay right there i'm
gonna get the door
you first i'll get the next time love it
right i do that was good advice it was
it was super it's slays dude i'm telling
you yeah we we i wanted you to be prince
charming yeah it worked that was good
advice she was really cute too that
first i don't know you went out i have
no record you always
dated really cute girls and all of them
loved you including their parents
the mothers the mothers were in love
with ethan well none as beautiful as my
uh your wife's the last greatest yes
absolutely the last and greatest that's
what i said she's a keeper you better
ask her to marry you yep you i did i
really did here pick a ring and my son
sean
i did the same thing
you bullied him into that i didn't bully
him
i said are you how do you feel about via
and are you in love with her is this
still all giving me advice or have we
moved well no i'm just sharing you know
and basically out of time
you know he was just like yeah of course
i love her and i go well then
do it already
you know and and he did
we did
and that brings us back to the birds and
the bees what do you think about the
pulling the chariot at the restaurant
that that one is just like a little
contrived maybe or do you like it
um you know it depends on the
circumstance but yeah i i do you do like
it i do does that i do it for you no
depends how far you pull the chair out i
guess because there are some practical
jokes along those lines you know but
when we were dating he always opened the
car door for me always
you always did when we were dating yeah
i mean but come on now like me you know
what do you want you want him to yeah
you got me i mean
we don't need to do those phony chivalry
things oh it's not phony
how about bringing a rose oh my god your
dad was so romantic
oh god don't tell me about it no no no
he he brought a rose and it's funny
because i was just talking to a friend
that's pretty common bring flowers i
mean
a single red rose it was it was white
rose it wasn't red it was white that's
what i said one single white rose it was
your mother's house
no it was from his his father was really
good
who took a rose he got mad at you no he
didn't say that
sure he couldn't tell
one thing that slays by the way
just on the topic of doing nice things
for girls that they really like what's
that hand picked bouquets
yes
pick some flowers from wherever you are
give them a little hand-picked bouquet
yes yes it's that's very sweet it's cute
it's very sweet and less expensive
that's not the point is not to is not to
save money that's not necessarily what
you want to open with is that hey i'm
i've saved some money
picking you these roads don't say that
you can think don't say it yeah i mean
it's easy to go to a store and just buy
roses or flowers more money to spend on
the date
broke ass there you go
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right we are have we didn't get time
to go to the advice because we had just
too much fun today yeah it really was we
just had too much fun we did some
bonding
did a little drama
and uh i think i thought it was a great
job it was next week we'll we'll do some
butterfly
yeah that's great that's funny i'm so
stoked
uh for the butterflies uh we'll just
keep we'll keep it condensed short i
don't want it long time you could do the
whole show no no no i say no
[Laughter]
never let it
all right guys thanks for watching
families we are back back back
and uh next week um we'll be back again
so
uh
keemstar
uh
uh eat [ __ ]
whoa
you can't stop me
here here he's not a good guy i was
trying to say like okay i want to insult
him but like we got to keep it
yeah i know he's going to complain to
youtube now i know what i can say ethan
said eat [ __ ] okay go [ __ ] on you can
shoot on cubesat all you want okay
keemstar
you need to update your look because
from the 14th century
that you know they had those beers like
the musketeers
look [ __ ] and and i think you're gonna
poke somebody in the eye with that
pointy beard
i don't know i just think it's so
bizarre that that that style amen
it's time to update that look yeah yeah
really got to get a new look dude he's
like my age right he's no no one's our
age he's pushing he's 40. yeah all right
yeah pretty much yeah about your age
he's older than me
oh yeah oh wait
wait dating a 20 year old so
pretty cool
i'm not gonna comment on that yeah i
know you're not the right guy to comment
on that honestly although that's a
20-year gap that's a big let's not talk
what are we doing we're entering the
show yeah
ciao smash that like button thanks
everybody
[Music]
you